hey everybody very very very big day
crazy weekend debate tonight we are in
the middle of the coronavirus crisis
which for some people means just gather
and you know pretend like everything's
fine and nothing is going on and spread
the disease even more for other people
that means behaving responsibly thinking
about the fact that just because you're
unlikely to suffer even if you got the
virus
you don't want to contribute to being a
vector to get other people sick who may
die and overly burden the healthcare
system including hospitals that are
rapidly running out of ICU space and
ventilators and so on and so forth so we
have a lot a lot to talk about in this
hour that we have before the debate
between Bernie Sanders and Joseph R
Biden Jr at the top of the hour we are
going to look at polls will we are
already seeing numerous states because
of the virus postponed primaries none of
the ones voting in 48 hours
but Louisiana postponing their primary
Georgia postponing their primary hello
and we're going to also look at some of
the things I've been posting related to
the virus over the weekend and just
people behaving and absolutely crazy
crazy crazy and insane ways we did
receive notice that Donald Trump tested
negative for coronavirus okay I mean do
any of us believe if he tested positive
that that they would tell us and as I
said yesterday on my Twitter page you
really should be following me on Twitter
what did I say yesterday let me see here
where was it I'm hearing Trump's score
on the quraían coronavirus test is one
of the highest doctors have ever seen
his natural ability for it was stunning
yeah anyway so I don't know I mean do I
I don't know that they would admit that
he had it if he did but we will look at
some of the things I've been posting it
as well okay
let's um giorgia scheduled to vote on
March 24 and they've postponed it so
let's let's first kind of set up what we
can expect for tonight because I'm
worried that some people have
unreasonable x-pac
patience for the debate tonight so we're
gonna do that momentarily we're going to
look at the polls if you're just joining
me remember if you're watching on
YouTube and you have questions or
comments and I love questions and
comments send them via super chat and
they'll show up in that gray box in the
bottom left which is very sadly saying
no super chats right now that's really
sad it's the it's it's bad for all of us
especially for me okay and if you're
watching on Twitch make sure that you
include a message when you grab a twitch
Prime subscription or twitch
subscription and then it will show up in
that vertical blue box very far above my
head and then of course we have a very
modest membership goal today of 25 new
members on my website at join pakman.com
you can use the coupon code 20/20 now to
get a 66% discount at the David Pakman
show
what we are doing to responsibly deal
with the virus is we are we've decentral
over the weekend we took that we made
the effort to decentralize our
production process so we will be
shifting to what is essentially a work
from home scenario decentralizing all of
the different elements it will have a
minor impact on the viewer experience
won't really have any impact on the live
streams we're gonna I'm gonna be a live
streaming coverage Tuesday night of the
elections we are doing everything we can
to be as much a part of the solution
rather than the problem as possible I
did not go and buy a six-month supply of
toilet paper or three years worth of
pinto beans I over the last month have
gotten a few extra things so they I have
you know an extra couple of weeks of
food beyond doing my normal shop no exit
might one local grocery store today no
yogurt very little milk almost no frozen
vegetables almost no frozen fruit the
fresh produce section was fine and I got
some delightful avocado avocados but
people are causing a problem and I'm
going to show you video in a little bit
of people fighting for toilet paper and
again this is an artificial shortage
there's no reason to think coronavirus
would lead to more toilet paper use
thus the fact that people started buying
extra just means we are creating an
artificial shortage okay let's put that
aside for now and get to the polling and
to the expectation for tonight listen I
I'm not gonna blow smoke up you guys
asses okay or gals anybody I don't even
care about gender nobody is getting
smoke blown up their ass here tonight
unless Joe Biden dies between today and
the elections on Tuesday night it is
very difficult to imagine the polling
reversing when the corporate media said
that Bernie's peak was 20 when he was
polling 18 they were wrong because then
Bernie hit 20 when they said that the
peak was 25 they were wrong because well
okay so I mean he they were sort of
right in that he hit 24 and then only
when people started dropping out that he
get any higher but Bernie's only getting
thirty percent of the popular vote in
the primaries so far
everybody's out other than Joe Biden I
mean I guess technically Tulsi still in
but nobody's paying attention to her and
it does appear as though Bernie's peak
nationally may be about 36 there's a lot
of people hoping tonight that Joe Biden
has what people are calling dementia
moments and that it's going to be so
embarrassing for Joe that everybody's
gonna change their mind and vote for
Bernie on Tuesday I don't think that
that's reasonable I think if you're
expecting that listen if you're hoping
okay if you're expecting that I think
that is extraordinarily unlikely and we
we need to understand that reality so
nationally Joe Biden now is winning by
more than 20 points importantly let's
look at the polls for the states that
are coming up which are which ones now
I'm actually forgetting so let's look at
Florida Illinois Florida Democratic
primary Biden is plus 43 you need a
bigger swing in less time than what
happened between South Carolina and
Super Tuesday in Bernie's favor I just
want people to understand that I'm not
telling you not to go and vote for
whoever you want to see win I'm just
saying if you're expecting an even
bigger swing in for
rather than 96 hours between now and
Tuesday night on the basis of tonight's
debate it's just very unlikely to happen
vote and make it happen right I mean if
that's what you want to see so Florida
is not looking very good Illinois is
also voting on and let me know I don't
have the list in front of me I'm
forgetting who else is voting on on
Tuesday in Illinois Biden is +30 on
average okay I mean they'll listen these
are difficult numbers these are just
this is just the reality so Bernie would
have to do something incredible tonight
to change that
and that's it okay whoo well so Florida
Illinois
I believe Ohio is vote voting on Tuesday
let's look at Ohio dem primary by we
only have one recent poll there and
Biden is plus 22 let's see who else is
Arizona okay let's look at Arizona I
appreciate people reminding me who's
voting on Tuesday Arizona Biden is plus
22 and we have a number of polls from
from the last few days Hawaii so I don't
know that Hawaii is actually voting on
not on Tuesday is Hawaii in any case I'm
not aware of a single state that bernie
is is winning from the Tuesday States so
okay wait let's see so Florida
okay in any case I don't think I have to
go one by one but but it's gonna take a
lot tonight so it'll be interesting to
see what happens in the meantime
coronavirus is wreaking havoc on the
primary Louisiana has postponed the
primary this was the first the first
primary to be postponed since the
outbreak Louisiana will postpone
originally scheduled for April 4 it will
be delayed until June 20 and remember
the primary is gonna be long over vite
by then so you know it's sort of
relegating Louisiana to to irrelevance
Arizona Florida Illinois Illinois Ohio I
think those are the four then that are
voting on on Tuesday Georgia which was
scheduled to vote on March 24th is
postponing to May 19 now I'll be
perfectly frank with you if people keep
acting like idiots and I'm gonna show
you some examples of that even May is
going to be even June conceivably might
be danger
because people are just not doing what
they're supposed to do you have mixed
messages from the completely incompetent
Trump administration coming forward I
have some incredible videos that I'm
going to be showing you in fact maybe if
we have time let me pull up a couple
things which maybe I'll show you you
have cut incompetence coming from
everybody you have a lot of people who
are acting like nothing is going on
whatsoever and if that's the case this
isn't going to be there is this dream
scenario of we peek in cases in ten to
fourteen days if this stuff continues
it's not going to happen and I'm gonna
get to that momentarily and I also want
to pull up one other clip that I wanted
to show people here it is okay and then
I will find that but just so people know
the the the debate is not until the top
of the hour so we're looking at a number
of different things between now and then
and we're gonna get to some other things
momentarily okay let me let me first
address a few things I have a couple
people telling me my website is down
which is sad that sometimes happens when
we do a live stream and a lot of people
are trying to sign up at once no it
seems to be fine so if you're just
joining consider supporting the stream
join pakman.com info is right up there
if you all the info is displayed you
grab a membership on my website we keep
almost all of that money when you do all
these other super chat all this other
stuff people are just taking slices
slice bigger and bigger slices everyone
wants a slice when you sign up at join
pakman.com we keep everything but 2.9
percent um and we have a coupon code
that's whacked it's crazy how big it is
20 20 now saves you 66 percent and we're
trying to get to 25 members today a very
modest goal but I invite you to be the
first the first person ok on twitch let
me say thank you to gas guzzler and our
Gila Burt for the twitch prime
subscriptions gold and Jericho says do
you think it'll be damaging for Bernie
to stay in until the convention or
should he stay in to try to push Biden
more left so Biden has already got done
a couple concessions on policy which
I'll be talking about tomorrow to Warren
and Biden and Bernie if you say to me
David not what do you want to have
happen gun to your head you've got to
bet money what do you think happens i
think bernie is probably out by
wednesday
if not by the following Tuesday that
that's my bet if you say you've got a
bet on a scenario but we will see I also
want to say thanks to Barefoot princess
for grabbing a twitch Prime subscription
okay over on YouTube
super chance are coming in Len a--the
says how do you think the virus will
shape the debate it will be the
framework for the healthcare questions
and answers is my prediction
Ryan Henry Dean says I got you big man
Thank You clockwork pineapple says David
have you smoked weed before I've never
smoked anything smokings terrible for
your lungs so I don't smoke anything
whether you give me a banana leaf or an
avocado skin or whatever you light it on
fire you say start breathing in the
smoke I'm a no on that Zac Finley has
sent in a super chat says hi anomaly or
anomaly both acceptable pronunciations
says oMFG the common cold destroyed the
world lol Joseph van Scoy says I think
it's time progressives move on from
Bernie tactically inept strategically
boneheaded hoping to see squad members
take a bigger role in the progressive
wing yep I mean listen you can check out
my videos which some people hate we've
actually lost thousands of Bernie ER
Buster's subscribers over the last week
and I don't say this to victimise myself
I say this just to tell you people are
furious that I've been pointing out
mathematical realities and data about
what's going on I can't control it
people coming in people coming out we
have audience rollover what can I do
folks what can I do um let's see Neko
Bambino says was corn pop really a bad
dude or just misunderstood I know very
little about corn pop Len a--the says
how do you think the virus will shape
the debate I could have sworn I just
answered that oh I did you sent it twice
okay
Shaner says Arizona voters you can now
vote at any vote center this election do
too many buildings opting out because of
the cool virus hit me up if you need a
voter map origins and tall tale says I
hope we get through it take care
everyone
Tyler Spillers says could the new date
for Georgia change anything for Bernie
nope kal Stevens Stevenson has grabbed a
youtube subscription and Danielle Beck
says benefit to vote Bernie
even though he can't win benefit - well
yes you get him delegates and
potentially negotiating power anthony
peasley says hashtag porter 2024 we need
future representation okay not sure I
know what that's about
in DISA unicorn says Trump raped a
thirteen-year-old girl and told her she
would disappear like Maria a 12 year old
he raved if she went through with the
lawsuit okay getting aggressive Jose
Jeremy Lowe says have you tried Edie at
pit bulls and pit bulls I am familiar
with yes I have more familiarity with
Edie babbles okay let me say thank you
to a few folks
Matthew Holmes has grabbed a join
pakman.com subscription Thank You
Matthew as well as Vadim Epstein Vadim
Epstein has grabbed a subscription at
join pakman.com ok let's look at some of
the stuff i've been posting here's
people so as Glenn Greenwald says with
kovat 19 all over Brazil and the country
already plagued by a systemically
dysfunctional and overburdened health
system here's what balsa narrow
followers encouraged by the President
and Allied Congress members are doing in
major cities ok I think you guys get it
disease vectors these people are not
helping one thing I've been following is
that there are certain European
countries of course Italy and Spain are
a disaster France is a partial disaster
there are certain European countries
that are holding down a very low death
rate as we are incorrectly calculating
it so far the right way to calculate
death rate is deaths divided by total
resolved cases meaning recoveries and
deaths and then adjusted for suspected
undiagnosed cases we are using what is
what is a very rough approximation but
if you look at these countries Germany
Switzerland UK Norway Netherlands Sweden
Belgium Denmark Austria you see that the
93 deaths over more than 15,000 cases
they are holding down a zero point six
percent death rate
that is far lower than we are seeing in
a lot of places I I'm wondering why and
there's a couple possibilities one is
that they have a less deadly strain of
the virus that's a hypothesis I'm not
saying that's the case number two their
healthcare systems are better equipped
number three
they've moved more quickly in limiting
that disease vectors transmission sites
by reducing public gatherings and all of
this type of stuff it's early right
meaning that a lot of these cases are
new and over the next two weeks sadly a
lot of those cases are going to lead the
deaths and the death rate is going to go
up a lot of different ideas about what
it is that is causing this here is Jerry
Falwell Jr remember his dad is the one
Jerry Falwell who said that 9/11 was
caused by people getting abortions and
gay people here is Jerry Falwell Jr
suggesting that this is all overblown
but more importantly that coronavirus
may be a bio weapon created by North
Korean dictator Kim Jong hoon mr. mee
how so many are overreacting the h1n1
virus in 2009 kills 17,000 people it was
the flu also I think and there was not
the same hype it was you just didn't see
it on the news 24/7 and it makes you
wonder if there's a political reason for
that it's it's you know impeachment
didn't work and and the Miller report
didn't work and so first of all already
equating corona virus which has Hilde
killed people disproportionately in
other countries to trying to impeach
Donald Trump article 25 didn't work and
so maybe now this is their their next
their next attempt to get Trump but but
I had a the owner of a restaurant asked
me last night
he said you remember the North Korean
leader promised a Christmas present for
for America back rent back in December
could it be they got together with China
and this is
present I don't know how but it really
is something strange he's just asking
questions guys going on well Jerry so
regarding the fact that you're gonna
continue to have classes right yet not
about the fact that you just asserted
without evidence that a bio weapon by
kim jongwan may actually be what we are
dealing with and of course as a gift to
trump which is mostly killing
non-american so far right okay so so why
are Christian pastors commenting about
the virus we need to hear from doctors
and we need to hear from scientists
epidemiologists etc okay it completely
and totally irresponsible unbelievable
okay before I get to the next video let
me say thank to us thanks to a couple of
other people Heidi
moraine is join pakman.com member number
three tonight the target is 25 Budhia
Tasi is new member number four at join
pakman.com tonight consider supporting
the streams that we've been doing and
there have been many by grabbing a
subscription at join pakman.com and in
the meantime if you're just joining on
youtube please remember to like and
subscribe the channel it's free it's
everytime people like and subscribe a
whole bunch of more people come into the
stream because YouTube's algorithm is
triggered for lack of a better term that
this is a good stream to suggest when
people like and subscribe so please do
remember to do that like and subscribe
if you're just joining us okay other
super chats coming in let's see here
adventure Edie says David would you take
Trump for four more years if we can get
a OC in 2024 I don't even believe she'll
be old enough because if Biden is
president there's no green New Deal or
Medicare for all until 2028 I'm not even
gonna dig into that because there are so
many false premises there that we just
it's it's we don't have time for that
right now
parity Ren well compare great to see you
honesty is more important than followers
that is my approach when people say
David you said Bernie doesn't have a
mathematical path I'm unsubscribing I
take it as in a sense the fact that
someone has been confronted with facts
they don't like and they're emotionally
reacting by unsubscribing I don't take
it personally I don't take it personally
in any way
the Britannic says what are your
thoughts on people who do not want to
vote for Biden even if he is the nominee
that's fine you know that it helps Trump
win so if they don't want Trump to win
then they or they do they can do
whatever they want I'm not gonna be mad
at anybody the it's just I just may
disagree with their approach Lenin says
how do you think Bernie will handle the
math do you if you I don't know what you
mean by that like math questions about
paying for stuff during the debate I'm
not I'm not sure I know what you mean
Twyla says you're progressives need
someone beyond vicious next time Sanders
moderated himself when he should have
politically disemboweled excuse me max I
choked on spit by the way that was not a
cough max says am i right to stop my
morning coffee routine at a never
crowded Panera in a small town in
Michigan you're not wrong listen here's
the thing if all of the social
distancing works a lot of people are
going to say we went crazy we did too
much it didn't make sense it was an
overreaction no the reason that we may
get out of this thing in the least seer
or in not the most serious way is
because people will do things that
seemed like an overreaction it's like
people who say why do we need vaccines
for these conditions that are so rare
they're rare because of the vaccines
okay
so you're not wrong ad Eric G says to
confirm you've tried edible edibles
before story time searched my YouTube
channel Adam Waddington says isn't it
counterproductive to say Bernie
lostalready OOP sorry it scrolled past
when you when young voter turnout has
been such an issue it seems like the
perfect way to deter is based from
rallying now that he would need it most
listen I do a show based on reality do
you want me to show up and say hey guys
it it's it's any it's anybody's game
when the odds are a 99.9% chance that
Joe Biden gets the nomination you want
me to come on and tell my audience
something that's not true I'm not going
to do it I've been saying this is the
math you can change the math by going
out and voting and getting other people
to vote that's what you know other shows
if you want different stuff you can go
to other shows that's how I'm handling
it Adam Despain says longtime fan here
please keep up the great work plan too
Kowalski from Nebraska says please shout
out Kowalski for congress.com Pro
Medicare for all and have climate
climate plan that age he likes
appreciate your insight and community
for ideas
let's go Bernie I thought Kowalski was a
Republican now I'm confused ascendant
says cheers for doing these videos David
you're bringing some intelligence to
these debates okay let me show you a
couple of other video clips as we wait
around for the debate at the top of the
hour I want to say a huge thank you to
Aaron Rennick who is join pakman.com
member number 5 tonight as well as Debra
Beck's 'ma whose new member number six
consider yourself invited to grab a
membership at join pakman.com I would
very much appreciate that okay let's see
here is Devin Nunez not Nunez remember
he wants everybody to know he's not
Hispanic he's Portuguese Nunez not Nunez
I'm half kidding sadly he was
interviewed by Trump brown-noser Maria
Bartiromo
on Fox oh I thought she was on Fox
Business but I guess now she's been
allowed over on Fox News his
recommendation is you should go to
restaurants right now because it's
there's nobody there it's really easy to
get her to get into these restaurants
and there's a lot of concerns with the
economy here because people are scared
to go out but I will just say one of the
things you can do if you're healthy you
and your family it's a great time to
just go out go to a local restaurant I'd
be likely you can get in get in easily
there's easy let's not hurt the working
people in this country that are relying
on wages and tips that don't run to the
understood just don't run to the grocery
store and buy you know four thousand
dollars of food don't go to your local
local pub so of course he's not wrong to
be concerned about the economy but the
point is the solution is a systemic one
why are we saying oh oh no all these
people if if people don't go into
restaurants they're not gonna make any
money well that's because the system
doesn't have paid sick leave
we don't have universal basic income we
you know all of these
stomach things why do we now have to be
doing the things we're doing well
because we disbanded the pandemic
response team Trump rejected the w-h-o
test because the CDC was going to make
one and then that imploded he's not
wrong to say in addition to people's
health we should care about the economy
the reason the economy is now in the
situation it's it is because
systemically structurally we've so
screwed up over the last many decades
this guy's disgusting half of my people
I asked should this be illegal I asked
it should it be illegal what he's doing
half the people that responded said that
yes it should be okay here is a girl I
don't know if she is merely ignorant or
also a bad person take a listen to what
she says and as she says it keep an eye
on this guy's facial expression yeah
she's fine I mean okay she's
immunocompromised
but she's 21 and takes supplements
supplements by the way and so she's out
having a grand old time on some kind of
block party for st. Patrick's Day so you
know again if this is going to continue
we are going to see many many
unnecessary unnecessary deaths okay as I
tweeted earlier my fault Whole Foods is
cleared out no eggs no milk chicken and
meat gone no yogurt no beans no frozen
vegetables no frozen fruit this is an
artificial shortage created by people
buying six months worth of stuff upside
is fresh produce was well stocked that's
a problem we are creating shortages we
have a big partisan divide right now as
you can see here Democrats far more
worried about their family because of
coronavirus twice as likely to be
avoiding gatherings twice as likely to
be changing travel plans three times as
likely to be avoiding restaurants so we
do have you know when we say not
everything is partisan that's right not
everything is but this is and you have
this information that has seemingly
metastasized within with with
Republicans let me see if there's any
other videos I wanted to show you guys
the toilet paper video
good news out of South Korea you can
check that out on my Twitter page D
Pakman let's see I was hoping
oh okay and this of course this is
Oklahoma governor Kevin stit last night
eating with my kids and all fellow
Oklahomans all my fellow Oklahomans at
the collective OKC it's packed tonight
this caused such uproar meanwhile I mean
we have a Republican governor here in
Massachusetts Charlie Baker he's doing
the right thing he's closing schools he
set up an executive order so that if we
need more nurses out-of-state nurses can
be licensed to work in Massachusetts in
just 24 hours that's thinking okay
that's a Republican and he's thinking
here we have this complete clown
governor Kevin stit bragging about going
out to eat to a crowded bar and he has
been so excoriated for this that he
ultimately deleted this tweet took it
down
what else did I want to say oh I want to
do the toilet paper video let me see if
I can find it actually before we do that
oh well you know let's let's do a couple
different things I want to do the toilet
paper video but I also want to do this
video what hold on a second is this let
me see it's the right one oh here it is
yeah okay we're gonna do this video in a
second but in the meantime I don't want
to fall back fall behind on thank yous
let me say thank you to Evy Jaa for the
twitch Prime subscription
Moondog says tonight's going to be grim
isn't it we will see Nilda 84 has
grabbed a subscription and shall diva
has also grabbed a subscription let me
say thank you to Susan kerlun Susan is
new member number seven tonight at join
pakman.com and John Taverna is new
member number eight tonight at join
pakman.com I appreciate that and if
you're just joining us on YouTube you
can get your super chats on-screen
that's the dollar sign down below you
can also it cost nothing make sure that
you hit like and subscribe like and
subscribe is very very important and it
does it does
a lot for our streams when you hit like
and subscribe okay let me do a couple
other super chats Brooks Madden says
David I'm poor you have an MBA tell me
how to make more money so I can buy more
stuff from your show you know I think
that exceeds the scope of today's stream
but yeah I've checked I have a bunch of
different business related videos on my
youtube channel
indica unicorn sends a picture of a
unicorn XO duct says this Democratic
primary is a pre example on how
important coalition building is in the
current political climate the
progressive movement cannot continue to
be a Rouge force a rogue force you meant
allies are needed absolutely
Trevor are says David do you think
Bernie lost potential voters by praising
Castro's literacy program I believe that
he did rightly or wrongly I believe that
he did copper sealed ooh sorry when a
bunch of super chats come in at once
it'll sometimes scroll is there any
conceivable bit way Bernie can win yes
if Joe Biden dies I believe Bernie would
win if Joe Biden so embarrasses himself
tonight that you know you see 60 point
swings in the state's voting Tuesday
that's what needs to happen thanks to
Mary Tellez for the super chat Lennon
says I met delegate math oh listen I'm
not gonna do the delegate math now let's
let tonight happen Tuesday night we'll
see where we are people they're mad at
mad enough at me for delegate math the
last Saint says Biden has not been able
to convince younger people to vote for
him and this means votes for drumpf via
apathy likely true to some degree
Charlie says huge rumor going around
that apparently Trump lost his testicles
and now wears Neuticles do you think we
will ever know the truth I've not heard
that rumor
it seems unsubstantiated Earling says
norway's on complete lockdown borders
closing down tomorrow schools
kindergarten universities are closed
international flights are returned I
read today that American Airlines is
essentially grounding all of their large
jets they're putting some jets like for
like I'm actually scheduled to fly on a
triple 7 from
Miami to Boston in two weeks I'm
guessing that trips not happening
but I guess they're all there leaving
three large jet
I don't insane but I guess they're only
international long-haul flights are
going to be Dallas to Tokyo Dallas to
London and Miami to London I read that
and it sounds absolutely crazy for
American Airlines to be doing that
absolutely crazy do you think oh wait
I'm sorry Jose jeremy lo says is it a
good thing or risky for the Treasury to
lower interest rates will it eventually
make interest rates for my bank lower
yeah I've been getting emails from my
high-yield savings banks saying we're
going down and what we pay by 25 basis
points because the feds down 25 basis
points so that will happen for sure
Damien Garvey says do you think Biden
will pick a progressive VP to pull in
Bernie supporter seems like a good
strategy I don't know I think it's
likely Biden picks either kamala or Amy
Klobuchar but who knows
JC pp has grabbed a youtube subscription
in dica unicorn says band aids don't
cost $65 for one well they certainly
shouldn't that's for sure green jester
says your opinion what if a progressive
tried running as a Republican
it probably let's gives the victory to
Trump would be my guess that would be my
guess if you're just joining us on
twitch make sure that you follow our
channel we are just about 419 followers
away from 30k which is great kiss may
has subscribed on Twitch and techno know
go has subscribed on twitch as well I
want to say thanks to sherry Ann Mansoor
Mansoor man sooner sooner Monsour sherry
Ann you were new member number nine at
join pakman.com very much appreciate the
support consider grabbing yourself a
membership okay let's take a look now at
this okay so foxnews is propaganda trash
it's garbage it's absolutely terrible
but every once in a while something
interesting happens here is video of
martha maccallum interviewing let me
remember her name dr. C
ma Verma who runs dr. Seema Verma runs
some department for the Trump
administration on disease okay this is
five minutes we're gonna listen to it on
playback speed 1.25 just to make it take
a little bit less time you are going to
see martha maccallum first of all you're
gonna want to watch her facial
expressions okay her facial expressions
as dr. Seema Verma does not answer two
simple questions what the hell's going
on with the tests you promised
outrageous numbers what's going on she's
not gonna answer and martha maccallum is
going to ask what about ventilators are
you worried about ICU space this is so
dishonestly transparently dishonest that
even Fox host Martha McCallum starts to
develop skeptical face is what I call it
just take a look at this embarrassment
coronavirus task force administrator
Burma thank you it's good to have you
here tonight
how are we doing on these tests oh I
remember last week I believe Alex a czar
the HHS secretary said that there would
be millions of them out there by the end
of the week has that happened you know
our focus is on making sure that people
that need tests can get tests and so
okay so remember that's not an answer
continued one of the things that's
already available is that at every
public health laboratory across the
nation these tests are available
okay so again see Martha McCallum is
asking about how many people can
actually be tested this is a ruse of
saying the laboratories have kits the
question is how many tests can they
actually process and how many are they
processing part of the non-answer what
we're working on now is to increase the
capacity in the private healthcare
system because most of us when we go get
tests we don't go to a public health lab
you're used to going to your doctor's
office they ordered the tests and that
usually is handled through our private
healthcare system and so we've been
working with the private system to
essentially ramp up so we can make sure
that those tests are available okay so
remember the question was you promised
millions if you know crazy numbers are
they available she says we're doing a
lot of different work we're talking to
people we're figuring out a process not
an answer okay continues so is it true
that there are millions of those is it's
now almost the end of the week so has
that mark been met that we heard about
from secretary is there because I was at
a doctor for something else the other
morning and asked and they said you know
we can't get him we've been calling we
called the state we called here
we can't get our hands on them and I
heard it from another doctor earlier
today with the same story with a patient
that so this is the second attempt and
she wanted to test and she tried to get
a test for that patient and was unable
to do so well today one of the things
that we did dr. Hahn and I hosted a call
with over 1600 representatives from
hospitals okay so the question was for
the second time are the freakin tests
available she says we hosted a phone
call with doctors work with them around
how they can do the testing inside their
hospital laboratories the other thing
that we're focused on is preparing the
entire healthcare system some of the
conversations that we've been having
with hospitals is making sure that they
have the guidance that they need so okay
so she's talking about we've been giving
hospitals guidance the question is are
there a million tests available or
aren't there one of the things that we
did just last week was give some more
guidance around emergency rooms and what
they need to do is I think we're seeing
emergency rooms across the nation's
setting out different screening sites so
that they can screen people for the
coronavirus on the front end those again
screening is the word screening is the
word they screening means take your
temperature okay then they keep using it
interchangeably when asked about testing
vigils don't have to come in to the
emergency room the other piece that
we're focusing on is infection control
we want to make sure that people don't
pick up the corona virus when they're in
a healthcare facility so we've asked for
all of the healthcare institutions
across America to double down on
infection control practices okay but in
terms of actual equipment so now she
moves on to asking about equipment
you're not going to get any answers
there Martha I'm sorry
we heard Bernie Sanders today for one
coming out and saying that there's a
major shortage of ICU units we've heard
that there's a shortage of ventilators
even swabs and equipment for the actual
tests what's being done about that and
how concerned are you that when we do
numbers do start to rise which doctor
fowey has told us to expect again the
question is what about the ventilators
there'll be enough ICU units and new
leaders to help the people who do get
sick in this country well that's why we
have an emergency prepared system you
know we're used to dealing with
disasters if we look at some of the
disasters that have happened around
hurricanes important so the question was
do you have ice use and ventilators she
says how about when hurricanes happen
Berto Ricoh in Florida there is a system
in place to make sure that folks that
are on the front lines have the
equipment and the supplies that they
need are you saying that we do them so
we're doing at CMS is to have reputable
care providers so we're meeting with
providers almost on a daily basis to
understand what challenges we're having
meetings again the question is do
we have ventilators and I see use we're
meeting with providers all the time
facing and what can we do at the
government level to support them and
help them and that's why we've been
putting out so much guidance guidance
based on these dialogues that we've been
having with the healthcare community
about the needs that they have there be
enough sure that people understand so
there Martha tries to ask question
number five she talks right over before
you go into your doctor's office you can
call your doctor on the phone and have a
discussion with them and they can tell
you whether you need to come in or not
and that's really important because we
don't want to have people hundr travel
unnecessarily if they're not we got well
know if they come into a health care
facility they could also be putting
others at risk and so we're encouraging
people to call their doctor remember the
question was do you have icy use do you
have ventilators she said call your
doctor
call your doctor we have screening
process in advance we're making sure
that that providers can use telehealth
and telemedicine right on to serve their
people
telehealth is not useful if you need a
ventilator doctor who's made that point
here quite quite a bit and I think it's
a very important point to make but
before I let you go I want to ask you
one more time are there gonna be people
in this country who don't get a
ventilator if they need one are you less
actual physical equipment that is needed
to serve the people who will get sick is
out there can you reassure everyone
tonight that there is not a shortage of
ventilators or ICU units and that's why
the president has taken such a bold and
decisive act so now she goes into just
she knows the interviews wrapping right
so at this point she's been told it's a
five-minute interview and it is probably
coming up against the heartbreak now she
just talks about how great Trump is ten
right we're not waiting for this to get
worse we're not waiting for this to be a
crisis in our health care systems and
that's why the mitigation strategies
that he announced so now by the way
Martha McCallum is smirking I limiting
travel from Europe not allowing that you
know we've given travel advisories on
cruise ships that's why we're taking all
of this action the question was I see
use she's talking about cruise ships
because we don't want to put stress on
the healthcare system okay a direct
answer to the question oh no no it's not
an answer at all it's not even an
indirect answer Martha but it sounds
like a hope that there won't be enough
sick people and we won't run that one
right ventilators because we have look
at the look on this woman's face like
how how does she feel when she leaves
this interview like the if you the only
positive feeling you could have is I
successfully ran disinformation
propaganda interference mitigated and we
certainly hope that we certainly hope
that's the case and the answer to all
these questions is no okay that's the
reality of what we're dealing with here
what I'll have a deeper analysis of that
on tomorrow's show okay let me say
thanks to a few other people Matthew
crib Lee has grabbed a membership at
join pakman.com and his new member
number 10 infos right there
Carter Quinn is new member number 11 at
join pakman.com brendan fodi
is new member number 12 at join
pakman.com jose manuel Lucena is new
member number 13 at join pakman.com
christina chapman is new member number
14 today and that gets us caught up
thank you so much we have a very modest
goal of 25 25 members today
okay other super chats that are coming
in if you're joining us the debate is at
the top of the hour if you're joining us
on youtube please do me a very small
favor hit like and hit subscribe because
it really does a lot for us and these
things are free it doesn't cost you
anything I won't be spamming you or
calling you with telemarketing phone
calls or anything like that like and
subscribe really does help our streams a
lot and we've tested it the more likes
and subscribes we get off of a stream
the more YouTube recommends the stream
and people just pour in like
paratroopers they just arrive to the
stream we don't know from where and it's
crazy okay Adams says if the situation
were reversed no one would be calling
this over and Biden would still be
playing for a contested convention if
the situation were reversed and Biden
was losing by 60 in some states I don't
know that it really would be any
different I don't know that I agree
Jorge Luis 88 it says hi David you're
such a cutie oh boy CJ sacks 87 87
Williams says Sanders showed disregard
to the reparations questions lost him
the your Biden got the old black folks
we need tangible okay I'm not sure I
totally understand that but I think I
get the gist
Tony Olynyk has grabbed the YouTube
subscription t machine sends a Spanish
Super chat saying
que onda papa alright Jay CPP says like
Martin like Bernie they
both spoke on social democrat it's a
movement it's not over just passing the
paithan i don't know if we have google
translate super chats coming in today
but i'm struggling with a lot of these
Daniel Krieger says thanks David love
you treilery says two weeks ago the
facts were that biden was left for dead
this election has been schizophrenic I
don't understand why your view doesn't
account for that okay I mean I said if
Biden dies tonight or you know loses the
ability to speak maybe it would turn
around that's how I'm accounting for it
adian says have you commented on UK herd
immunity approach not yet no maybe
tomorrow
CJ sax issues a clarification that still
doesn't really help me figure out the
message Kent Smith says oh and it just
scrolled past hold on where did Ken
Smith go Ken Smith says your opinion on
Trump's efforts to buy exclusive rights
to German vaccine development firm cure
vac and more development to the USA I'm
still reading about that and I'm going
to comment on that tomorrow don't do I
don't have anything a firm yet Rock Lee
says double-date with me and no me key
constants Destiny's lame okay
Shiv sac Sena retract Sam essage IDO
says how should progressives sharpen
their message and try to expand
popularity in their agenda biased cable
news outlets are huge obstacles I've
already given my thoughts on that in a
bunch of clips and there's no way for me
to do it without being critical of the
way it was done and I don't want to piss
people off on the eve of so many
elections so let's let the table that
for now Michael Bradley says would you
consider putting these YouTube special
broadcasts up as an audio podcast you
know we tried that a couple times and it
didn't work that well so we will think
about it
hound dog says kovat 19 is making vote
blue no matter who much more attractive
to me I won't hesitate to vote for Biden
in November if he's our guy listen I
know there's two views on the effective
of the vie so aside from the effect that
the virus might have on voting itself
like postponements and stuff
like that there's two views one is
coronavirus will make it so obvious we
need Medicare for all that Bernie's
about to win every primary I think it's
unlikely that that happens but it may
happen I actually think that coronavirus
and Donald Trump's disastrous handling
of it will help the eventual Democratic
nominee no matter who they are it's not
playing politics it's just understanding
that this will have an effect that's the
most likely effect in my mind
Dustin DPS says thanks for your honesty
never sugarcoat it appreciate that
lord or says I wouldn't be surprised if
someone would put up put a bit on Joe
before the primaries are announced I
wouldn't want that to happen but it
seems possible put a bit on Joe I don't
know that is bit um slang for something
I'm not sure I know what that means
um Twila says coronavirus under Boris is
a bad time to share a land border with
the UK that an international peace
treaty demands never be closed
interesting the sandbox bandit says do
you think the virus will be treated like
a war and it'll get Trump reelected
since people wouldn't want change
captains midstream well Trump is already
using the language of war I don't know
if you guys notice he talked about we
have the the power to fight this and
he's already using war language so I
think that's his only bet quite frankly
Oh a hit on Joe Biden I'm not even gonna
yeah I'm not even gonna address that
that's that's not that's not that's not
for me there might be other channels
that want to do that - Fat Bastard says
thanks Dave you are the cure for Trump's
pandemic idiocy and Shiva Saxena is back
Dave can you really not pronounce indica
do you not smoke that good shade right
experience music devastated by Biden's
rise when do you think we'll see another
one like Bernie I say at least 15 years
what will should can Bernie do with
incredible grassroots infrastructure
he's created
Bernie should try to use the delegates
he's accumulated and try to negotiate
stuff into Biden's platform in exchange
for dropping out because he's eventually
going to have to how long will it be
before the next Bernie
I think it'll be less than 15 years Alex
D vote blue no matter who because the
Supreme Court is on the line that's my
view reasonable people can certainly
disagree let me say thanks to Nexis
quadruple one on for the twitch Prime
subscription we are at nine nine nine
twitch subscribers the next twitch
subscriber will be number one thousand
palatini on has subscribed oh and there
is Sun bro Sun bro is twitch subscriber
number one thousand thank you very much
also thanks to Firebird double X for the
twitch Prime subscription we're about 13
minutes from Bernie vs. Biden at the top
of the hour thank you for joining me I
very much appreciate it if you're just
coming in the YouTube stream plz like
and subscribe it's free and it feels
good to do it and it'll get me to shut
up about it too okay let me say thanks
to david guerrero david guerrero is new
member number 15 today at join
pakman.com and oh okay I think that's it
I thought I had another person to thank
but I don't thank you too David Guerrero
for signing up consider getting a
subscription at join pakman.com okay
when Trump is vice president I'm sorry
when Trump runs for vice president in
2024 who will be his running mate pence
Don jr. or Ivanka
yeah the royal couple Ivanka and Donald
would be running I have no idea our rich
ropa thak says would rave Dubin
celebrate coronavirus even though it's a
conspiracy against Trump
since we're social distancing moving
away from the collective I have no idea
I've not seen a Dave Rubin clip outside
of the few seconds I've played on my
show for I think at this point a very
very long time
Dougie says how would you react if Biden
shows Hillary as his VP I would react
negatively it would be it would be
weaponized negative reaction will kovat
19 benefit the economy in the long run
by forcing a transfer of wealth and
higher paying jobs to younger people who
spend more there's there's so many
variables I
couldn't possibly speculate on that at
this early stage
Davis handler asks is it likely there
will be a homeland military response if
it gets out of hand I would not be
shocked if things got out of hand I'm
not saying they will if things get out
of hand I wouldn't be shocked to see the
National Guard deployed in a sort of
peacekeeping sense
Lenna says even if Bernie fails to
secure the nomination what are your
thoughts on how he has contributed to
the progressive movement going forward
listen before 2016 Medicare for all and
universal health care were not
mainstream topics a freak free public
college tuition was not a topic college
of student loan forgiveness was a topic
but not as widely discussed the fact
that the wealth inequality is a problem
it's just a matter of how to fix it
that has changed under Bernie there's no
question that Bernie Sanders has changed
the narrative and now it's a question of
who can make some of those policies a
reality that's that that's essentially
the question slam brew says bernie
equals progressive Barry Goldwater
you're not the only person to speculate
on that cosmic antimatter has grabbed a
subscription Patrick toaster says yeah
Trump handles the crisis terribly but
the Swiss government isn't better now we
have the second highest rate per capita
well you have a lot of cases but a very
low death rate very low death rate and
hopefully it stays that way Martin
Anderson says nothing sends a super job
Ryan Henry Dean says don't forget to
like the stream yes listen to Ryan like
the stream if you're watching on YouTube
Martin Anderson says for more Trump ears
means 7 to 2 conservative Supreme Court
no doubt no doubt I have made that point
and that is absolutely absolutely and
completely the case now you may not care
there are people who say I don't care I
don't care about that I'm going to I
just I cannot vote for Joe Biden and
then we just have to live with it if
that's the case let me say thank you to
squid tips cast for subscribing with
twitch prime as well as crib Li for
subscribing with
twitch Prime Melinda rows Fitness sends
a super chat
Alex D has subscribed mitai Matthias
Hummel says what's your opinion
concerning Trump's failed attempt to buy
the German company cure vac I'm in a
comment about that tomorrow I've not
read enough about it yet to say Kacey
Bassett says I'm a comic-con promoter
I'm hosting a large supernatural
convention in Pittsburgh called memento
Con scheduled for May 9 to 10 Friday the
13th was my Black Monday working to
postpone yeah I had a bunch of paid like
nice good paid speaking gigs that are
postponed at this point it's all falling
apart he who wears pants says where do
you find time to read all the books you
recommend seems like it seems like
you're busy as f with the show and live
stream and whatnot yeah I usually read
like 20 minutes I try to read at least
25 non-fiction pages a day which is
really not that much I'd love to be
reading 50 but usually I'll wake up and
read 20 20 minutes or so and then
usually like in the afternoons between
producing the show and streaming or if
I'm not streaming at night I'll read
nonfiction Jim I'm by the way I am
reading one of the Ben this I read a lot
of nonfiction books okay I'm reading one
of the best narrative nonfiction books
that I think I have ever read it's
called hunting Eichmann by Neil bascomb
and it is the story of the tracking of
Nazi Adolf Eichmann - my birth city of
Buenos Aires Argentina the Mossad
operation to capture him bring him out
of Argentina on a charter El Al flight
to Israel for trial it is its narrative
nonfiction which Neal bascomb assembled
from thousands of documents transcripts
it's it's it's almost a work it's a work
of science and it's a work of art how
Neil Bascom has been able to do this the
book again is called hunting Eichmann e
IC h MA and n Adolf Eichmann one of the
biggest
captures of a living Nazi in 1960 in
Argentina
it is a page-turner and it is uh
incredible and I didn't actually realize
how during the operation to get Eichmann
in Argentina they had a good lead on
Josef Mengele the Nazi doctor doing all
those insanely disgusting medical
experiments and they almost had him and
he had just left a boarding house where
he had been living very shortly before
the team arrived it's like it's crazy
anyway so Neal Bascom hunting Eichmann
very very good let me say thanks to Jim
Oberst for the membership
Sam Dean says g'day Dave Victoria goes
into official state of emergency from
12:00 noon today starting tomorrow
supermarkets will have one hour in the
morning dedicated to the elderly and
people with disabilities seems like a
very good idea crib Lee says member
coupon was too much here get yourself a
roll of toilet paper yeah 20 bucks is
about what what they're costing these
days news now auditor Omaha cop block
says Omaha cop block on YouTube morph
Cogan says how much reading and
knowledge gathering do you do a day um I
don't know a couple hours as much as
possible Lord or says it was hit damn
autocorrect let me say a couple of other
thank-yous before the debate starts
Alexander Luna is new member number 16
today at join pakman.com Thank You
Alexander I so appreciate your support
fo q or v q as i think is supposed to be
right if bernie loses the nomination
right in bernie sanders yes if you want
Trump to win definitely do that say
feeis says would aoc be able to run in
the next presidential election even
though she would be 35 in the primary
but 35 by the general don't know the
answer Roswell Satterwhite says it won't
matter in the polls but you think Bernie
will strongly outperform Biden tonight
or will they fight to a draw I have no
idea I'm as curious as you are and on
that note so we've made the decision
because today's debate is on CNN and CNN
has pre
we brought down the banhammer honest not
only on YouTube but also on twitch
because it's so important that we be
able to stream election results this
Tuesday and next Tuesday and so on and
so forth we are going to essentially go
offline during the debate and I'll be
back for the post show after the debate
okay so I know that it sucks we would
rather all watch it together we've
determined and speaking with legal
counsel accounting security staff and by
that I mean I just asked my couple of
employees about it we we've decided
we're not going to stream the full
debate it's just too risky for us and I
would love to do it as much as at least
a handful of the people watching would
want to so we'll be back after the
debate for the post show memberships
will carry over all of that stuff I'll
see you then apologies we can't do it
another way but it's it's gotten to it's
gotten too hot so to speak